checkmating with the two Bishops is
really not that difficult all you have
to do to learn is watch this video and
then practice the end game on your own
or with a friend a couple of times until
you get the technique
down after that you'll pretty much be
set for a very long time the first thing
you guys need to remember is that you
need to force the enemy King into one of
the four corners of the board
that's the only way you'll be able to
deliver Checkmate and I'm sure you've
already seen this idea when trying to
checkmate with the king and queen or the
king and Rook right it's always easier
if the enemy King is in one of the
corners of the board basically because
it has less squares that it can go to
there which means it's easier to
Checkmate right now I'm just going to
play out a sample end game and explain
to you guys all the basic ideas and
principles that you need to know in
order to be able to do this
yourself the first thing I'm going to do
is just bring my king towards the enemy
King okay simple enough if you're on the
other side of this end game and you're
trying to survive you need to keep your
king in the center of the board as much
as you can that's the only way to make
things somewhat difficult for your
opponent so both Kings come to the
center and let's say we get this
position okay now my king can't come any
closer so it's time I use the two
Bishops that I have extra right and I'm
going to start with this move
here what I like about this end game is
that you don't actually have to give any
checks until the very end if you want to
Checkmate the king all you need to do is
take away squares from the king so that
it can't stay in the center of the board
and it's eventually going to be pushed
into one of the corners so here I'm
taking away the important E6 Square
which means that the king cannot stay in
the center of the
board if the King goes back to E7
then I'll bring my king one step forward
and I'm that much closer to forcing the
enemy King to the edge of the
board so let's say the king comes around
this
way now I'm going to bring the other
Bishop in to
F4 now I'm controlling the D6 Square as
you can see the two Bishops work
together very well when you control both
colors you're creating this laser beam
that has already made the top right of
the board completely inaccessible to the
enemy
King a really fundamental thing that you
guys have to remember in order to be
successful in this endgame is that black
always has to make a
move what I mean is you're not allowed
to pass a turn in chess always have to
move and that's useful information to us
because if we constantly ask ourselves
where is my opponent going to go next
then it becomes very easy to determine
which squares we need to take
away let's say the king comes
here and we're trying to figure out what
move to do
next right the move I want to play is
Bishop D6 because I know now the king
can't go back to C5 and if I ask myself
where is the king going to go next I
know that it's going closer to the edge
of the board either to
C3 or to
B5 either way I'm making progress if the
king could just stay on C4 and black
could just keep passing there would be
no way to make this Checkmate work right
so it's really important that you
remember that the king always has to
make a
move so King
C3 now I hope you guys can guess this
next move if you need more time pause
the
video Bishop E6 now I'm just taking away
more and more squares from the king so
that eventually it is forced to go into
one of the four
corners okay let's say King D2 trying to
get back in the center of the
board now I'm going to play
here not allowing the king to stay in
the center at
all if he goes to E1 then I'm going to
bring my king in and we've made tons of
progress since the king is already on
the edge of the board so let's say the
enemy is very resilient and he plays
King
C3 now I'm just going to play back
here now look all these squares are
being taken away from the king and you
can really see how easy it is to
checkmate with the two Bishops right
just continue to take away squares and
eventually the enemy will have nothing
to do but to go back into the
corner the king comes to B3 I'm going to
play King
D3 right as soon as you can get your
king closer to the enemy King it's
probably a good idea to do so now the
king is again forced to go closer to the
corner so let's say King goes to D2
and now we can give this check right the
point is not to give the check but we
realize that the king cannot cross over
to that side of the board and is forced
to move closer to the edge which is
where we want the king to go so King
C2 now where does the king want to go
wants to go here again right so how
about Bishop
C4 again the two
Bishops are fantastic at creating this
force field that stops the king from
going
anywhere King B2 now we can bring our
King
in and the king is forced to the edge of
the board and now we can play
here controlling the
square King comes up no
problem you can just play
here King goes back to C1 and our King
King gets into a great position so the
king is forced even farther into the
corner and now it's just a matter of
precision and taking a little bit of
care the only way you can mess this up
now is if you stalemate your
opponent right if you get really
careless and you do something like
this stalemate right no good you want a
Checkmate so a great way to avoid that
is to ask yourself a simple question
again where is my opponent going to
go so if you're considering this move
and then you ask where is he going to go
King A1 all right great and then if you
want to play King C2 and you ask
yourself where is he going to go you're
not going to be able to come up with an
answer because it's stalemate so you've
saved yourself from that embarrassing
situation where you stalemate in a
opponent with two extra pieces
right
so again great way to avoid that is just
ask yourself where are they going to go
now in order to finish this off all you
need to do is bring your king even
closer to the edge of the
board okay so this move was
fine and now you have to take a little
bit of care so you can just bring your
Bishop back King is trapped so he has to
go
to
B1 and you bring your king over here the
King has to go to
A1 and now we have a simple Checkmate in
two great now that you watched me
deliver this
Checkmate I want you guys to review the
video and then practice this on your own
Okay just set up a board give yourself
two Bishops make moves for your opponent
right make them reasonable moves keep
the king in the center as long as you
can and then Checkmate using your two
Bishops right if you practice this a
couple of times you should be able to do
it in under 30 moves okay the rulle say
you have up to 50 moves to Checkmate
before the game is a draw but if you can
do it under 30 you'll be in great shape
and you'll never have to worry about
that 50 move
rule that's pretty much all there is to
it just remember a few basic things use
all three of your pieces including your
king to take away squares from the
enemy and constantly ask yourself where
is the king going to go next that'll
give you a big hint as to which squares
you need to take away and logically
you'll be able to figure out how to
force the king and push him further turn
further back into one of the corners
where you'll be able to Checkmate him
with the two
Bishops thanks a lot for listening and
I'll see you around on chess.com